[Music]
good morning John this video comes in
three parts and I know what you're
thinking
three perches in very many parts Hank
and this video isn't very long well I'm
sorry really am part one
I just finished their two little blue
envelopes if you'd like to be
entertained while also being educated
and also subconsciously prodded into
going to Europe as soon as humanly
possible this is the book for you
actually went moved two plane tickets
about halfway through very well done if
you have not bought it yet buy it so
that you can participate in the birthing
book club as soon as possible let you
know what the next blurbing book club is
before I wrap up this blurbing book club
book so that you can get it in hand and
be ready to read it for those two weeks
next well for those of you who are
saying you need an extension because it
takes a little bit of time for Amazon to
get booked to your house this will go
fast don't worry just go get it and
you'll be fine
part two is the part where I talk about
how I've kind of been spying on you and
also stealing your money you may not
know this but I decided to put an
affiliate link in the Amazon link in the
sidebar so that we'd make 25 cents every
time somebody bought a copy or 32 little
blue envelopes the cool thing is that we
not only get to see how much money we
make which has been like $10 it's been
amazing uh but we also get to see what
people are buying and so now you see
because you've been giving me 20 cents
for every book you buy at amazon.com and
I've kind of been checking up on what
you guys are buying on amazon.com but
it's been very interested nerdfighters
have some interesting buying habits but
when I say interesting I mean nerdy for
example somebody bought a copy of
elsewhere buy will shed early which is
one of my all-time favorite books a
story about a young nerd who gets taken
in by a no-armed woman who runs a
bookshop and also about develops their
fires somebody bought the entire
original Star Wars series which is
something that honestly we should all
own nerdfighters other titles include
nerds who they are and why we need the
nerdfighters probability and statistics
for engineering in the sciences
nerdfighter
solar energy projects for the evil
genius eco geek nerdfighters the gifted
kids Survival Guide nerdfighters and of
course Fraggle Rock the Fraggle Rocket
Edition DVD set nerd fighters you people
when you shop at Amazon you do not
forget to be awesome part
free Valentine's Day I didn't really
expect to get any Valentine's this year
except maybe from Kathy
ah but I did the Boston awesome
nerdfighters at the Boston area
nerdfighter gathering also called bang
made me a bunch of avid Hinds and want
to share some of them with you
they made John some too and then
couldn't post it so that I could send
them to him which I will do shortly and
I have not done yet I'm sorry this one
is from Helen Hunt but on the back it
says actually it's from me zoom i zoom
it sue who has been a nerdfighter from
the very beginning have an evil lady
baby Valentine's Day there's Queen R and
Valona robideaux and Rihanna pointing me
over one over Cassandra says Hank loved
Angela meanie
it's spelled Minnie but it's pronounced
meanie okay I love you from Boston party
bozos this may be one of my personal
favorites please head here putting your
head on stuff is a little bit of a
turnaround in the putting stuff on your
head thing but it works just the same
this one's shaped like nerdfighter
fingers and references the valens time
joke I'm Ashley third fire and this one
says I am truly outrageous and it says
hug Sarah and it says v-day 1987 I don't
understand why it's 1987 what why is it
v-day 1987 Sarah okay Thank You Boston
area nerdfighters I will treasure them
forever and I made a Valentine for
Katherine that I kind of want to share
just in case there are any Jane Austen
nerdfighters out there that's all for
now don't forget to be awesome